hey guys Pete here today's Game of
Thrones Season 8 video is going to be
about the end the end of the season the
end of the series and the end of the
cultural phenomenon that has become Game
of Thrones this is not the video I
wanted to make today I've been working
on something else but people are still
freaking out about the twist and
Daenerys story and on the one hand I get
it but on the other hand I don't agree
with it so so rather than put out my
unpopular opinion which I more or less
did in my video yesterday today I
decided to focus on something different
and that is what is the sweet part of
the bittersweet thing gonna be we are
definitely experiencing the bitter side
of it and george RR martin has always
said the ending would be bittersweet so
let's look at where that might come from
so Daenerys and John have been the
center of the story and where things
left off in episode 5 it's starting to
become very apparent that Daenerys
cannot make it out of the series alive
there's always been this problem that
her dragon makes her too powerful now
that we've seen her used that weapon of
mass destruction on the small folk and
everyone else that lives in King's
Landing it's pretty clear that she'll
have to go so overall this kind of leans
towards the bitter end for both John and
Daenerys personally I like the idea of
John leaving for the real north I like
him living out his days in a
self-imposed exile with ghosts I think
that is somewhat sweet at least in the
sense that he's never liked doing what
he is good at which he is a warrior he's
a killer he's good at getting other men
to follow him into the fight so going
north leaves him some peace in that at
least in my imagined idea of what he
would do some people believe that he's
going to take the black which at least
at this point we don't really know that
there would be a Night's Watch
so I don't like that as much and makes
sense in that if he kills Daenerys then
you know he would have to do something
to make up for his crime but I still
prefer the other
version daenerys like I said can't
really survive to the end of the game so
my hope is that her vision of the people
never being subjected to living under
the rule of tyrants will be realized
after she's gone this is definitely
bitter for Daenerys herself it's it's
bitter for Daenerys fans I get that my
point is not to be insensitive and that
but for the common people the small folk
the people that have been paying the
price in this system that was set up by
Daenerys his ancestor Aegon the
Conqueror it's a pretty sweet deal there
is a possibility for life to get better
and that hinges on what is in place
whenever the story is over we don't
really know that for sure but I think
it's safe to say that anything that
george RR martin cooked up would not
involve someone with the potential of
being a tyrant ending up on that throne
i laid out what i think is going to
happen to Daenerys in my video yesterday
I think it really makes the most sense
for John to take her out course arya is
a popular choice among people as well
i'll get to arya later in the video but
i just want to say for john if he's the
one to swing the sword it does complete
the balance so you know he played a
major role in getting people to fight
against ice the white walkers taking
care of that and then he actually had to
deal with the human threat of course
aided by the power that comes along with
dragons and their dragon fire but here
you know it's a lot more difficult he
has to do something that he wouldn't
otherwise do he has to do that for the
greater good for mankind just like they
did when they fought against the white
walkers and it's certainly not happy but
it's sweet in the sense of like sweet
dude you saved the world you know from
there I think we really have to look
towards the secondary characters and I
think that an epilogue will play a part
in that I made another video like this a
couple days ago for a different platform
when I was thinking about things I mean
obviously Sam and Gilly they seemed like
the top candidates for a happy ending I
definitely want to see what happens with
them
what their future looks like sometime
down the road this has a lot of
possibilities because Sam's close with
John Sam's close with bran when we saw
them last they were still at Winterfell
I don't know why they would really stay
there beyond that so I want to see them
have a happy ending and I want to see
what that looks like I want to see where
they end up I want to see how many
children they have I want to see how
they're prospering after the wars the
next thing that stands out to me when
I'm thinking about this is the lowborn
guys who played a big part and things
turning out the way they did ginjury is
the first example I think it would be
great to see him down the road as Lord
of storms and I mean he grew up in flea
bottom we watched his adventure I mean
he deserves whatever good he can get for
playing the part that he did Davos is
another guy that has come from humble
beginnings and played a huge role in the
series the show never talks about his
wife it's almost like he doesn't have a
wife in the show but he definitely does
in the books of course he still has a
son that's alive at the end of the books
too so I don't really know what's in
store for Davos I think that he could
probably play a role in establishing the
new government or a new council or
wherever that goes but there's also a
possibility that he can roll on out and
go home and live with his wife and live
out his years in retirement bran is
another guy he is not my favorite but he
is definitely a fan favorite and I think
that we're gonna find out what goes down
with him people want to see him get his
castle and I think he probably will but
that should sweeten things up a bit
especially for his fans after episode 5
I really am rooting for Arya after her
talk with the Hound after we saw her
walk away from killing Cersei choosing
life if you will and then we had this
great sequence or where they have her
show us the real horrors of
war and the pain of the small folk and
the way that more grinds the people down
and I read some negative reactions to
this like people didn't want that from
her point of view but I don't really
understand those she is the one who took
us through the Riverlands and gave us
that look into the war of the five kings
she's not the only character but I don't
know who else could really do that for
us that's still left in the story and it
bookends perfectly for her she lost her
family she had to live on the run saw
the horrors of the war of the five kings
and the way that affected the regular
people in Westeros ran away to Braavos
became an assassin became a killer when
she had to be but at the end she walks
away from it all and we had that great
exchange between her and Sandor so I
think that is definitely a sweet turn of
events to put some sweet and bittersweet
I hope that she doesn't kill Daenerys
for this reason I hope she doesn't kill
drogon I hope she doesn't kill anybody
else in the series if you want to know
my opinion doesn't mean that she won't
do those things but the original name
for the final book was a time for wolves
and I want to see a time for Arya where
she gets away from the death that has
been surrounding her for the entire
stretch of the series torment is another
bright spot I guess sometimes you can
forget that torment is a redemption
story as well you know he was killing
people with the wildlings like wiping
out villages under mance rayder
he came around he's taken them back
north to the real north so that's pretty
sweet in a way well I don't love
everything about what happened with
salsa in the last two seasons she is one
of the characters who has a sweet ending
to a very bitter story she ends up being
what she wanted to be she's well
equipped for the position she had a
brutal road to get to that place and
that is a bright spot as well so to sum
it all up I don't think there's gonna be
some kind of joyful or euphoric event
that's just going to fill us with love
and happiness and send us away with a
smile but I do think that the people
will be better
I think the threat that's been looming
with the white walkers will certainly be
as neutralized as they are now they seem
to be non-existent and I think that by
making that full turn by crossing that
line Daenerys has set things in place so
that there will never be another
Targaryen that sits on the throne
so that cycle will be truly broken and
keeping with the idea of a time for
wolves I'm sure we'll see Sansa make it
through become the Lady of Winterfell of
course she's gonna be on the wrong side
of Daenerys but I don't think that
that's gonna play out and be anything by
the end of the story I hope that we'll
see Winterfell in the future and we'll
see how the north has rebuilt itself all
of that comes at great cost of course
but I want to see the family endure
after surviving the winter and that is
really where I end up so let me know
what you think where is that coming from
the sweet in the bitter sweet I think
Jon embodies the bittersweet as a whole
he brings balance he takes care of the
existential threats but there is a great
cost and he has to sacrifice the one
that he loves in order to make it happen
but yeah let me know what you think
please like the video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already I know what I'll be
doing in a couple days time and I will
definitely be making videos about the
series finale so check back for those
thanks for watching I will talk to you
soon